μάλιστα τα ροπλάνα που πεδούσαν πάνω από το κεφάλιμου τον ίχο μέχρη τώρα κάποιες μέρες
μήναμε καρκετές μέρας από την πρώτη μεχρι δεύτερης βολύ μήναμε σε μια άκτη στην πολικατηγία
με το οπογι έρκουνται τούρκει νέρκονται τούρκε πμου αλέποτ βάλιστα στοσόσαλμύτιας ναι γα την αμόχως
το δείχνεις κάποιες πολικατικίες που μεγάλωσες ναι κρις του κόσμου όλα τράδιώμα κριβώς πιόποτε αναφέρουμε
σε αυτάε πιανν έν τώρα συνεστήματα μεχριπου θερον αποιαν τα κλάματα τοτά τα βιώμανα φριστομετράβήματα
ίνε πέρασε αι και στο βιβλίως σου τω έερσαρέντ ερτο ποίο επηρεσ σχεδόδεατρία μέ μια
τοτεγίω ακριμότα βιώματα π ραπεριβόταης ων το ιβλίοέντα πολύλογώτο απάρουμε λίων πιο γρήγορα φύγαμε αευιό
ξαμμασι τούρκι μιαμενεσήσαμε στυνάχνα σε μια βράντα κάμποσες ημέρες πάλι έρχονται τούρκε ν έρουνται έχονταιν
ρχουνται δ εγαν πήγαεγαδέστερες τα υγούς του με στν άχνα φύαμε ημου νεπατριώς μου ημητέρα
μου αδελφός μου είχων και υπιο παιθκιά που των πρώτων του γάμω μαζί μα ήμα
μιαπιος χύλλους ιαμε στη λευκωσία σε ένα διαμέρισμα ογδώντα τέτρα γωνικά τις γιαγς μου τις
ελένεις τις πάρα στης μητέρας μοζήσαμε νεκήρκιοτρία χρόνια οκτώ άτομα σε ένα σπίτι μια κατάσταση
άστρα μην την περιγράψω λοιπόν νκαι ακολούθησε μιανα εγαφήσως ατα αφήσω τα παιδικά χρόνια μεν
προχωρήσω ότι να το πιάσουμε να λίγον πιο γρηγορά πγαν στο δημότικό σχολείον λιγαβητού στην
ακρόπολη στο τελείωσα το στρατών πέρασα στη νομική ναθυνών είχαέναμεόλη αυτή ζωή όλα αυτά τα
βιώματα μου δημουργήσαν πάμπολλα ψυχολογικά προβλήματα το κάτα περιγράφομε σα στο βιβλίω πυ χα τια
γνοστήμετκα εφτά διανοητικές διαταραχές μια από αυτές ήταν αγορά φοβία δεν μπορούσαναμιλήήσου αυτό που κάνουμε
τώρα κιαμένα ήταν κάτι το ξωπραγματικών έτσι μπήκαν στο σχομπήκαν στη νομική πέρασα τα μαθήματα
σε όλα με τη λογική ους